nos piden que simplifiquemos esta enorme
expresión gay x al cubo más 3 x menos
seis más entre paréntesis menos 2x más x
menos 2 - entre paréntesis 3x menos 4
aunque entonces pues lo que tenemos que
hacer es respirar profundo y no pensar
que está enorme e ir paso a paso lo
primero que vamos a hacer es tratar de
deshacernos de estos paréntesis y aquí
tenemos que tener cuidado porque tenemos
1 - entonces lo vamos a distribuir y
entonces pues empecemos aquí tenemos x
al cubo x al cubo y después tenemos 3 x
3x y finalmente menos 6 menos 6 nos
deshicimos de este paréntesis porque
realmente no le está haciendo nada a
estos términos así es que vamos con el
siguiente del siguiente paréntesis pues
este más no le está haciendo nada al
paréntesis así es que también podemos
simplemente quitarlo y lo que nos queda
es menos 2 x al cuadrado menos 2 x al
cuadrado más x
las equis y finalmente menos 2 - 2 ahora
aquí tenemos menos y todo el paréntesis
o sea que estamos restando todos los
términos que estén adentro del
paréntesis de hecho podemos pensar que
aquí le estamos poniendo un menos uno y
estamos multiplicando este menos uno por
este paréntesis y entonces tenemos que
usar la propiedad distributiva y lo que
nos queda es menos uno por 3x que es
menos 3 x + menos 1 x menos 4 que es
simplemente más 4 aunque y entonces
llega la hora de agrupar los términos
entonces buscamos en toda esta expresión
el término que tenga una x con el grado
más grande está x cuyo grado estrés
porque es x al cubo y entonces vamos a
buscar si hay alguna otra x al cubo
no este es el único término de grado 3
así es que agrupando todos los términos
de grado 3 nos queda simplemente x al
cubo entonces vamos a buscar y agrupar
todos los términos de grado 2 ok
aquí tenemos 1
y listo es el único término así es que
por aquí nos queda menos 2 x cuadrada y
ahora vamos a buscar y agrupar todos los
términos de grado uno por aquí tenemos
uno éste nuevo aquí está otro y este es
el último ok entonces nos queda 3x más x
menos 3x así es que éste se va a
cancelar con este porque 3 x menos 3 x
pues es 0 y entonces simplemente nos
queda más x más x y finalmente tenemos
que agrupar los términos que no obtengan
x osea este término con este término
ella espera se me estaba olvidando no me
fijé que aquí había otro término que no
tenía x aunque no les debe de pasar eso
pero bueno aquí tenemos menos 6
más menos 2 eso es menos 8 más 4 o sea
que tenemos menos 4 menos 4 y listo
hemos terminado de simplificar toda esta
expresión gigantesca y nos quedaron nada
más cuatro términos